now second peter chapter 3 verse 8 tells us that
one day with the lord is as a thousand years
and a thousand years as one day we know that the
earth is about six thousand years old according
to the the genealogies written in the bible and
also the writings of ellen white so this question
is how does the millennium this thousand years
relate to the rest the earth was to experience
well the earth the rest is that there's no sin
being committed there's no temptation going on
the earth is in a state of rest from all the moral
turmoil that has been occurring for six thousand
years as a result of adam having submitted to
satan's whatever wilds and guiles so that's a
thousand years we ellen white frequently refers
to for six thousand years this has happened
for six thousand years she says that frequently
and since i believe she's a genuine servant of god
i take that seriously it does not lead me to set a
date by any means i set no dates but i do believe
we're not we're not far from the end because the
final event will be very few and very rapid and so
the thousand years uh yes on this earth there's
no there's no one alive just the devil and his
angels no one to tempt nothing to do just to think
and think of thing and so there is in some sense a
period of rest not perfect rest because perfect
rest requires the absence of sin and all the
evidences of sin so even the christian has not
yet experienced perfect rest because he or she
is still living in a world of sin live in a world
with prisons and hospitals and war and disease and
plague and prophet like in ebola virus and zika
whatever else so in that sense we have not yet
entered fully into god's rest it is when christ
comes the third time who destroys the wicked burns
of the earth and the heavens restores everything
brand new then we will finally enter into that
rest but for the thousand years there is some
sort of rest from all the sins that are normally
committed amen and you know i'm seeing the
intersection between the sabbath day of rest and
also the rest from sin i'm thinking about hebrews
chapter 4 um verses 1 through 11 where where
god literally says that because of unbelief the
israelites did not enter into the promised land
and then we also hear about god creating the
seventh day and how there remaineth a rest for the
people oh god you see this is how beautiful on uh
the sabbath is so beautiful not only arrests from
physical labor but also from this from the chains
of sin and from the the inclination to go against
god friends we want that rest when jesus comes a
third time thank you for answering yes they did
not enjoy perfect rest because they did not cast
out all the tribes as god told them so there was
there was still occasional harassment from time
to time so they did not fully enjoy the rest
god intended for them again it was because of
unbelief they did not do what god said and so
let me stress again total rest will come when sin
and all its evidences and these consequences are
finally blotted out and we live in the new heavens
and the new earth wearing breath righteousness
amen amen thank you so much olga skeet